From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. And to explain the idea behind this week's radio show, I need to tell you about this date that one of the producers of our show, Jane Feltes, went on recently. There was this guy who she talked to briefly after a rock show, and then the guy called Jane's friend Ray for her telephone number. And Ray is a really good friend of Jane's, and Jane says that Ray was all for this. Ray saying things like, you really should date this guy.
这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台的《美国生活》节目，由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。为了解释这期节目的主题，我得跟你们讲讲我们的一位制作人简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）最近的一次约会。她在看过一场摇滚演出后，与一名男子有过短暂交谈，后来那男子向简的朋友雷（Ray）打听她的电话号码。雷是简非常要好的朋友，简说当时雷极力促成此事，甚至对简说：“你真的应该和这人约会。”
Like this is going to be great. And he would use these arguments like, he went to BU. I don't know what that-- is that Boston University?
就好像这会是一段美妙的缘分。他还用了一些理由，比如：“他毕业于波士顿大学（BU）。”我不知道那是……那是波士顿大学吗？
Yeah.
是。
Is that a good school?
那是所好学校吗？
I don't know.
我不知道。
I don't know either. He's like, he went to BU, he's friends with Joe Biden's nephew.
我也不知道。他说，他毕业于波士顿大学，还是乔·拜登（Joe Biden）侄子的朋友。
Right. Not Joe Biden.
没错。不是乔·拜登本人。
Or Joe Biden's nephew.
而是乔·拜登的侄子。
Jane is recently single, so she figured, why not, might as well see what happens. But comes the night of the date with a friend of the nephew of Joe Biden, and things start badly. She's about to leave work to go meet him, and she gets a text message that he's going to be late. About an hour later, she gets another one. She waits.
简最近单身，所以她心想，为什么不呢？去看看会发生什么也无妨。但到了和这位“乔·拜登侄子的朋友”约会的当晚，情况却很不妙。她正准备下班去赴约，却收到一条短信说他要迟到了。大约一小时后，她又收到一条短信。她只好继续等。
It had passed after, after-work drink time, and then it passed regular dinnertime to like, now, 10 o'clock. And I thought, I'll give him the benefit of the doubt, because you never know. Maybe he would show up, and he would have like, a big shark bite or something.
当时早就过了下班后喝酒的时间，也过了正常的晚餐时间，现在已经十点多了。我想，还是再给他一次机会吧，因为说不准会发生什么。也许他会赶过来，而且可能还带着像被鲨鱼咬伤之类的借口。
Just to name one of the common reasons why people show up late for dates.
这只是人们约会迟到时常见的借口之一。
I don't know. Well, that would-- I mean--
我不知道。好吧，那确实……我是说……
It would totally explain it.
这完全能解释得通。
It would explain a couple of hours.
这倒是能解释那几个小时的耽搁。
When the guy finally arrives, he does not have a shark bite, but he is 100%, totally, completely stoned. They walk to a restaurant, where the guy does not try to be charming. He does not really talk much at all.
当那名男子最终出现时，他并没有被鲨鱼咬伤，但他整个人看起来百分之百、彻底地喝高了（或者吸大了）。他们一起走向餐厅，但那个人一点儿也不想表现得迷人。他几乎全程都没怎么说话。
And then he kept doing this thing, I think because he was so stoned, but I'm not sure. But he kept doing this thing where I would be talking, and he kept like half closing his eyes, and then he would go-- he would like shake himself awake, an he'd be like, wait, sorry, what? I just tuned out just then. Over and over and over again.
而且他一直做那个动作，我想是因为他神志不清，但我也不确定。但我说话的时候，他总是半闭着眼睛，然后又……他会把自己晃醒，说：“等等，抱歉，你说什么？我刚才走神了。”一遍又一遍，没完没了。
When the bill came, they each took out credit cards. Jane figured they'd split this. But when he saw her card, he put his away and let her pay for the whole thing. And then it was time to go. The guy asked if Jane wanted to smoke another joint. Jane pointed out that she hadn't been there for the first one.
结账时，他们各自掏出了信用卡。简以为他们会平摊账单。但当他看到简的卡时，他把自己那张收了起来，让简支付了全部费用。接着就是离开的时候了。那人问简想不想再抽根烟。简提醒他，刚才第一根的时候她都没参与。
So when you leave this date, what are your feelings about Ray, who set you up?
那么，当你结束这次约会时，对于给你牵线搭桥的雷，你有什么感想？
I mean, all kinds of stuff went through my head like, do you see me as so desperate? I mean, I'm really close with Ray. He is one of my best friends. I couldn't see how he put the two of us together. I couldn't see how he thought we would make a good match. I started taking it personal like, oh, there must be something really wrong with me if one of my closest friend thinks this is the kind of guy I deserve.
我是说，我脑子里闪过各种念头，比如：我在你眼里就那么绝望吗？要知道，我和雷非常亲近，他是我最好的朋友之一。我完全看不出他怎么会把我们撮合到一起。我无法理解他为什么觉得我们合适。我开始往心里去，心想：天哪，如果我最要好的朋友之一都觉得我只配得上这种人，那我一定是哪里出了大问题。
Well, you know, we should call your friend Ray.
嗯，你知道，我们应该给你的朋友雷打个电话。
I'd love that.
那太好了。
Hello.
喂。
Hi, Ray.
嗨，雷。
Hi, Jane.
嗨，简。
OK, I'll just summarize a little bit here of what happened next. Ray was apologetic about how badly the date had gone. And he reminded Jane that he really didn't know that guy very well. And then we got to the big issue at hand.
好的，我就简单总结一下接下来发生的事。雷对约会搞砸了表示歉意。他提醒简，他其实并不怎么了解那个男人。然后我们谈到了问题的核心。
Jane has a question for you, and, if I can paraphrase the question, the question is, why did you think that he would be a good date for her?
简有一个问题要问你，如果我能转述一下，问题是：你为什么会觉得他是个合适的人选？
The answer would be threefold. First, he was friends with Joe Biden's nephew, who is like a pretty good guy.
理由有三点。第一，他是乔·拜登侄子的朋友，那个人人品还不错。
OK, you don't even need to hear the other two reasons. They made just as little sense as number one. But after talking for a while, Ray did finally explain the fix up this way.
好了，你甚至都不需要听后面两个理由了。它们和第一个一样荒唐。但在交谈了一会儿后，雷终于这样解释了他为何要撮合他们。
You always get the guy who's too rough. This guy seemed like-- since he had like a clean-cut haircut, and he was like a college guy-- He was kind of like friends with the bad guys. So you could go out with the bad guy. He seemed like a normal guy too.
你总是遇到那种太粗鲁的男人。这家伙看起来……因为他留着干净利落的发型，像个大学生。他算是那些坏小子的朋友，所以你可以和“坏小子”约会。他看起来也像个正常人。
This is so crazy, because I had no idea you'd given it this much thought.
这太疯狂了，因为我完全没想到你居然考虑得这么深。
Up until this point, Jane had no idea that Ray saw her this way, or that he felt so strongly about who she dates that he might actually try to fix it. When you set up your friends you can't avoid revealing what you really think about them. Things you haven't even told them. You're sticking your neck out more then they are when they go on the date.
直到此时，简都不知道雷原来是这样看待她的，也不知道雷对她的约会对象如此操心，甚至试图干预。当你为朋友牵线搭桥时，你不可避免地会透露出你内心深处对他们的真实想法，那些你甚至从未对他们说出口的话。你其实比他们本人承担了更大的风险。
And so we have for you today an entire show of people meddling, interfering, thinking they know what's best for others. We've got Yentas, we've got busybodies, sometimes for good, sometimes for ill. Our show today-- Matchmakers. We have three stories in three acts. Act one is a match done out of pure giddiness. Act two is somebody who matches up people who, the most important thing they'll ever do together, they'll do the first time they meet. Act three is matchmaking between real children and plastic children. Stay with us.
所以今天，我们为你们准备了一整期关于人们如何爱管闲事、如何干预他人生活，以及自以为最了解他人的节目。我们有“媒婆”，有“好管闲事的人”，有时出于好意，有时却帮了倒忙。我们今天的节目主题是——媒人。我们将通过三幕故事来呈现。第一幕是纯粹因一时冲动而促成的缘分；第二幕是一个人试图撮合一对男女，而他们在一起后做的最重要的一件事，竟然是在第一次见面时发生的；第三幕是真实儿童与塑料玩偶之间的“牵线”。请继续收听。
Act One, a Good Year for Grand Gestures. The matchmakers in this next story try to bring two people together who love each other. But there are different kinds of love, and different ways to think about love as they discover. Gregory Warner tells what happened.
第一幕：宏大举措的好年份。下一个故事中的“媒人”试图撮合两个相爱的人。但正如他们所发现的那样，爱有不同的种类，人们对爱的思考方式也各不相同。格雷戈里·沃纳（Gregory Warner）讲述了接下来的故事。
Once upon a time in Afghanistan, a tall, curly haired man named Mohammed Sabir saw a short young woman at his brother's wedding. He never said a word to her, but he was smitten. And normally. that would have been the end of the love story. In Afghanistan, men aren't allowed to talk with strange women. But this one was different. As the younger sister of his brother's new wife, she could visit Sabir's house with her parents. Sabir could even manage to sit next to her on the couch, which he did three months later.
从前在阿富汗，一个身材高大、有着卷发的男人叫穆罕默德·萨比尔（Mohammed Sabir），他在哥哥的婚礼上看到了一位年轻的小个子姑娘。他没跟她说过一句话，却对她一见钟情。通常情况下，这就是爱情故事的终点了。在阿富汗，男人是不允许与陌生女性交谈的。但这次不同，作为他哥哥新婚妻子的妹妹，她可以随父母来萨比尔家串门。萨比尔甚至有机会和她并排坐在沙发上，三个月后，他终于做到了。
Was that the first time you talked alone to a girl that wasn't your sister?
那是你第一次和除了你姐妹以外的女孩单独交谈吗？
Yes, that is my first time.
是的，这是第一次。
Sabir speaks some English, but he brought along his friend Dr. Wasai to help translate the rest.
萨比尔会说一点英语，但他带上了他的朋友瓦赛医生（Dr. Wasai）来帮助翻译其余的内容。
[SPEAKING  FOREIGN LANGUAGE] It was very delicious time for me.
[外语] 那对我来说真是非常美妙的时刻。
He said it was sweet and tasty?
他说那是“甜蜜而美味的”？
Yeah, it was sweet and tasty, and his body also was shaking.
是的，他是说甜蜜又美味，而且他当时身体还在发抖。
And while he sat there shaking, Sabir told the girl she was very beautiful. The girl, whose name was Kotsea , told Sabir he had nice hair.
就在他坐着发抖时，萨比尔告诉女孩她很漂亮。那个名叫科特西娅（Kotsea）的女孩告诉萨比尔，他的头发很好看。
If it was possible, I will take your hair on my head.
如果可以的话，我会把你的头发长在我的头上。
She wanted to put your head on her head? What did that mean when she said that do you think?
她想把你的头长在她的头上？你觉得她说这话是什么意思？
It means-- know he is in love with her.
这说明……他正深深爱着她。
All that flirting over the hair was racy enough by Afghan standards, but what happened next says Sabir, could have gotten him killed. He went over to his brother's house. And he found Kotsea alone in her bedroom. And then, violating every rule he'd ever been taught, they kissed.
在阿富汗的标准来看，关于头发的那些调情已经足够大胆了，但萨比尔说，接下来的事甚至可能让他丧命。他去了哥哥家，发现科特西娅独自在卧室里。然后，违背了他所受过的所有教条，他们接吻了。
After that one kiss, our love became the stronger and the stronger.
在那一吻之后，我们的爱情变得愈发强烈。
The stronger their love got, the more secret they had to be. Sabir was then 28. Kotsea was 18. They'd steal looks over the dinner table. Quick glances, Sabir says, like camera flashes. They decided to get married.
他们的爱情越强烈，他们就必须表现得越隐秘。萨比尔当时28岁，科特西娅18岁。他们在餐桌上偷看对方。萨比尔说，那是像照相机闪光灯一样快速的瞥视。他们决定结婚。
I said for she, I love you. She says, I love you, you can marriage for me? I said, OK, no problem. I wait for you.
我说：我爱你。她说：我也爱你，你能娶我吗？我说：好，没问题。我等你。
She said, I'll wait for you?
她说：我等你？
Yes, yes, she's wait for me.
是的，是的，她在等我。
Sabir needed about $10,000 to get married. $4,000 for her father for her hand in marriage, another $6,000 for the wedding itself. But Sabir doesn't make that kind of salary. He's a driver for a Dutch development organization. He saves maybe $30 a month. At that rate, it would take three decades to raise what he'd need. So each year, Kotsea would wait, and each year Sabir would tell her, he didn't have the money.
萨比尔需要大约1万美元才能结婚。4000美元给女方父亲作为彩礼，另外6000美元用于举办婚礼本身。但萨比尔赚不到那么多钱。他是荷兰一家发展组织的司机，一个月大概能攒下30美元。照这个速度，他需要三十年才能凑够钱。所以科特西娅每年都在等，萨比尔每年都告诉她，他还筹不到钱。
Four years passed. And then something happened which should have had nothing to do with either of them. Sabir's boss, Nikaj van Wees, went to a party at the Dutch embassy. There Nikaj met an American aid worker, and he fell in love with her. Her name was Miriam. Before that, Nikaj had a pretty regular work relationship with his driver, Sabir. They didn't talk about personal stuff. But when Miriam moved in with Nikaj the mood changed. Miriam talked to Sabir as a friend.
四年过去了。然后发生了一件本应与他们俩毫无关系的事。萨比尔的老板尼卡杰·范·威斯（Nikaj van Wees）去参加了荷兰大使馆的一次派对。在那里，尼卡杰遇到了一位美国援助工作者，并且坠入了爱河。她的名字叫米里亚姆（Miriam）。在那之前，尼卡杰和他的司机萨比尔之间只有单纯的工作关系。他们从不谈论私事。但当米里亚姆和尼卡杰同居后，气氛变了。米里亚姆像朋友一样和萨比尔聊天。
I was in the car with Sabir, and I asked Sabir, so are you married? Do you have a wife? Do you have kids? He says, oh no, sir. He calls me sir. Oh no, sir.
我在车里问萨比尔：你结婚了吗？有妻子吗？有孩子吗？他说：噢，没有，先生。他叫我先生。噢，不，先生。
This is Miriam. She is sitting at the dinner table next to Nikaj.
这是米里亚姆。她正坐在尼卡杰旁边的餐桌旁。
And so is there a girl? Is there a girl? Oh yes, sir. Do you love her? Oh yes, sir.
所以，有姑娘吗？有姑娘吗？噢，有的，先生。你爱她吗？噢，是的，先生。
He's brownish, but he got a very red head.
他皮肤是棕色的，但他的头非常红。
He can blush. He is the only Afghan I've ever seen who can turn beet red. And I said, are you going to marry her? Oh no, sir. I don't have money, sir.
他会脸红。他是我见过的唯一一个会脸红得像甜菜一样的阿富汗人。我说：你要娶她吗？噢，不，先生。我没有钱，先生。
Here's how it usually works when a man can't afford the dowry to get married. He waits for his sister to get engaged, and then he uses the money she gets for her dowry to pay for his new wife. It's like a dowry recycling. But Miriam found out that Sabir's father broke that tradition.
当男人付不起彩礼无法结婚时，通常是这样操作的：他等待自己的姐妹订婚，然后用姐妹的彩礼钱来支付自己新妻子的聘礼。就像彩礼循环利用。但米里亚姆发现，萨比尔的父亲打破了这一传统。
Because his father doesn't believe in selling his daughters. So the fact that Sabir's father never charged a dowry for his daughters means that Sabir doesn't have any cash to pay for his own dowry.
因为他的父亲不相信卖女儿。所以萨比尔的父亲从未向女儿索要彩礼，这意味着萨比尔没有任何现金来支付他自己的彩礼。
And that seemed particularly tragic to Miriam and Nikaj, who were just beginning a fairy tale story of there own. Before they met, both of them were in unhappy relationships. The last place they expected to find their soulmate was Afghanistan. But Miriam had only been in the country a week when she met Nikaj. And a few weeks after their first kiss, she was flying back to America to divorce her husband. Nikaj flew to Holland to break up with his long-term girlfriend.
这让米里亚姆和尼卡杰觉得特别悲剧，他们俩刚开始属于自己的童话故事。在相遇之前，他们都在一段不幸福的关系中。他们最没想到的就是在阿富汗找到灵魂伴侣。但米里亚姆到那个国家才一周就遇到了尼卡杰。在第一次接吻几周后，她就飞回美国与丈夫离婚了。尼卡杰则飞往荷兰与相处多年的女友分手。
It wasn't just love, it was that giddy, you won't believe what I found, stage of love, when you think things like, gosh, wouldn't the world be perfect if everybody could find this? It's when lovers are at their most dangerous and prone to set you up with their friends. As Miriam planned her wedding with Nikaj, she was bugged by Sabir's story.
那不仅仅是爱，那是爱情中那种让人眩晕的、“你不敢相信我发现了什么”的阶段，那种让你觉得“天哪，如果每个人都能找到这样的爱，世界该多完美”的感觉。这是恋人最危险、最容易给朋友牵线搭桥的时刻。当米里亚姆筹划她和尼卡杰的婚礼时，她被萨比尔的故事打动了。
I wanted to give them something. A heart gift my mom calls it. I wanted to give them something that meant something to me that was more than a token. And so Nikaj and I chewed on this for a while. And that, along with the fact that we didn't want any gifts, gave us an idea. So we had the idea of passing the hat around, so to speak. Instead of gifts, they could donate to the Sabir wedding fund.
我妈妈管这叫“心意礼物”。我想给他们一些对我而言有意义的东西，而不仅仅是个象征性的东西。所以尼卡杰和我琢磨了一阵子。加上我们不想收任何礼物，这就给了我们一个主意。我们想到了“募捐”的方法。与其收礼，不如请大家为“萨比尔婚礼基金”捐款。
If we marry, he marry.
如果我们结婚，他就结婚。
If we get married, he gets married.
如果我们结了婚，他就结婚。
But their friends are all aid workers, and they don't have much money to give. So it fell to Miriam and Nikaj to scrape together the money Sabir needed.
但他们的朋友都是援助工作者，手头并没有多少钱。所以，筹集萨比尔所需的钱落在了米里亚姆和尼卡杰身上。
But in giving $10,000 to an Afghan that you met six months before, Miriam was breaking one of the basic rules of development work. In all her years in the business, she'd never given away even $100 to someone. One of her jobs is to certify new aid workers. That includes teaching them not to fork over their own cash, because you don't want people to always be turning to you to fix their problems.
但向一个只认识了六个月的阿富汗人捐赠1万美元，米里亚姆打破了发展工作的基本原则。在从事这一行的多年里，她甚至从未给个人捐过100美元。她的工作之一是考核新的援助工作者，包括教导他们不要掏自己的腰包，因为你不想让人们总是找你来解决问题。
If one of my staff, if an ex-pat came up to me and said, yeah, I'm giving $10,000 to this family, because I really like them, I'd say, are you nuts? I would have said, you're crazy. Because I don't give money to beggars, not usually. I believe in the bigger plan, funding hospitals, and orphanages, and education centers. You don't just give money away. That's just not what you do. So don't mess with the system. Yeah, you don't want to set that precedent of I give, you receive. And so that's, I guess, in some ways, how this broke my personal rule.
如果我的员工，或者哪个外籍人员跑来跟我说：嘿，我捐了1万美元给这家人，因为我很喜欢他们。我会说：你疯了吗？我会说：你疯了。因为我通常不给乞丐钱。我相信大局规划，资助医院、孤儿院和教育中心。你不能随便乱给钱。这不是你应该做的事。所以不要破坏系统。是的，你不想树立那种“我给，你收”的先例。所以，我想这在某种程度上打破了我个人的原则。
But Sabir also broke the rules, she said, because he was the one who chose Kotsea. It wasn't a match made by his family, as almost all marriages in Afghanistan are. That appealed to Miriam. It felt like true love.
但她说，萨比尔也打破了规则，因为他是那个选择科特西娅的人。这不是由他的家庭促成的婚姻，而在阿富汗，几乎所有的婚姻都是包办的。这打动了米里亚姆，感觉就像真爱。
He doesn't want any girl. He's really fixed on this one, not anybody, this one. And I think that's what originally drew us to him. That's unusual in Afghanistan. And I liked that. I don't know. It felt like a good year for grand gestures. We were really excited about life in general, and we felt like spreading it out. And Sabir seemed to be the best direction to put it in.
他不要别的女孩。他就是认准了这一个，不是任何人，就是这一个。我想这就是最初吸引我们的地方。这在阿富汗很罕见。我喜欢那样。我不知道，这感觉像是一个实行宏大举措的好年份。我们对生活感到非常兴奋，我们想把这种快乐传播出去。而萨比尔似乎就是最好的方向。
So Miriam and Nikaj put $2,500 in an envelope, a sort of down payment on the girl, Kotsea, . And they gave the envelope to Dr. Wasai, Sabir's friend, who also works for Nikaj. And Dr. Wasai took the money to Sabir's house, and he sat down with Sabir's family to arrange everything. And that's when he found out they hated the idea.
所以米里亚姆和尼卡杰把2500美元装进信封，算是给女孩科特西娅的定金。他们把信封给了瓦赛医生，萨比尔的朋友，他也为尼卡杰工作。瓦赛医生带着钱去了萨比尔家，和萨比尔的家人坐下来商量一切。就在那时，他发现他们根本不赞成这个主意。
They ask me, his father and his sisters, they asked me, please talk with Sabir. We are not happy with that girl.
他们问我，他的父亲和姐妹问我，请和萨比尔谈谈。我们对那个女孩一点儿也不满意。
Turned out Sabir's family knew all about the secret fling. They'd suffered for years the googly eyes, the flash of the camera looks at the dinner table, and they thought Kotsea was a terrible match for Sabir. They didn't worry as long as Sabir didn't have the cash, but now he had foreign backers, international money from Nikaj and Miriam. The family marshaled against intruders. Even Wasai told Sabir to drop the girl. She was too short, he said.
原来萨比尔的家人对这段秘密恋情了如指掌。他们忍受了多年那些眉来眼去、餐桌上的闪光灯式的注视，他们认为科特西娅对萨比尔来说是个糟糕的搭配。只要萨比尔没钱，他们就不担心，但现在他有了外国赞助者，有了尼卡杰和米里亚姆提供的国际资金。家人联合起来抵制入侵者。甚至连瓦赛都劝萨比尔放弃那个女孩。他说，她太矮了。
I told him, reject her, and dump the agreement with her, because Miriam and Nikaj, they are the same tall.
我告诉他，拒绝她，结束与她的协议，因为米里亚姆和尼卡杰，他们一样高。
Miriam and Nikaj are the same height?
米里亚姆和尼卡杰一样高？
Yes, and Me and my wife, we are the same tall. And when you're touching with your wife, all the parts of your body will be separate from each other.
是的，我和我妻子，我们也一样高。当你和妻子亲热时，你们身体的所有部位都会恰好对应。
Sabir is sitting next to Wasai on the couch. Not laughing, just looking down at his hands, giving me a full view of his thick, fluffy hair. In the end, it didn't matter how tall Kotsea was, her father said no to the marriage. Sabir was just a driver, he said, with a rented house. He wanted a better provider for his daughter.
萨比尔坐在瓦赛旁边的沙发上。没笑，只是低头看着双手，让我能清楚地看到他浓密蓬松的头发。最终，科特西娅有多高根本不重要，她的父亲拒绝了这门婚事。他说，萨比尔只是个司机，还租房住。他想为女儿找个条件更好的供养者。
And so it was over. Sabir was heartbroken, still single. And Miriam and Nikaj were left wondering what would happen to their $2,500. Two months passed. and then I met again with Sabir and Dr. Wasai. And Sabir told me this.
一切就这样结束了。萨比尔心碎了，依然单身。米里亚姆和尼卡杰则纳闷他们的2500美元会怎样。两个月过去了，我再次见到了萨比尔和瓦赛医生。萨比尔告诉了我这个。
And then I'm with a new girl.
现在我有了一个新女孩。
Sabir had a  new fiancee.
萨比尔有了新的未婚妻。
She is a very good, beautiful girl. I like her.
她是个非常好的、美丽的女孩。我很喜欢她。
The new girl's 22, he tells me, just like Kotsea is. But this one was chosen by Sabir's sister. She's Sabir's nephew's high school classmate, and everything else was done in accordance with tradition. Sabir met the girl's father, the father gave Sabir a bag of candy, Sabir gave the dad some of Miriam and Nikaj's money.
新女孩22岁，他告诉我，和科特西娅一样大。但这个是由萨比尔的姐姐挑选的。她是萨比尔侄子的高中同学，其他一切都符合传统。萨比尔见了女孩的父亲，父亲给了萨比尔一袋糖果，萨比尔给了准岳父一些米里亚姆和尼卡杰的钱。
She is taller than the first one. She has nice hairs. I know for they showed to me her photo.
她比第一个高。她头发很好看。我知道，因为他们给我看了她的照片。
You've never seen her? You've only seen her photo?
你从来没见过她？你只看过她的照片？
Yes, I receive a photo, not see she.
是的，我收到了一张照片，没见过她本人。
Sabir hadn't even seen the new girl, which made this a very different kind of love story. No secret kisses, no stolen glances, no tortured tale of young love. It felt about as romantic as a mail order catalog. And Sabir sounded so practical.
萨比尔甚至还没见过这女孩，这让这成为了一种截然不同的爱情故事。没有秘密接吻，没有偷看，没有年轻爱情的痛苦传说。这感觉简直像邮购目录一样实际。萨比尔听起来非常务实。
Are you in love with the new girl?
你爱这个新女孩吗？
Yeah, now that she's my wife. I love her.
是的，既然她现在是我的妻子。我爱她。
You do love her?
你真的爱她吗？
Yeah, yeah, because she is now my wife.
是的，是的，因为她现在是我的妻子。
I won't play you tape where I kept asking Sabir to compare the new girl to the old one. He got uncomfortable. I felt like a spoil-sport. And finally, Wasai told me to drop it. Look, he said, Sabir's 32 years old. He's never talked to any other women, let alone been in a relationship with somebody. Sabir thinks he was in love, Wasai says, but it was something else.
我不会放录音给你听，因为我一直在让萨比尔把新女孩和旧女孩做比较。他变得很不舒服。我觉得自己像个扫兴的人。最后，瓦赛让我别再问了。看，他说，萨比尔32岁了。他从来没和别的女人说过话，更别说和谁建立关系了。萨比尔以为他坠入爱河，瓦赛说，但这其实是别的东西。
Pseudo love. Pseudo love.
伪爱情。伪爱情。
A pseudo love? Well, we would call it lust, I think.
伪爱情？嗯，我想我们会称之为“色欲”。
It means, the young boy get a little bit thirsty, especially in Afghanistan.
意思是，年轻男孩有点渴了，特别是在阿富汗。
Wait, the boy is very thirsty, you said?
等等，你说男孩非常渴？
Yes, and for example, when you drink some things more and more, you are not thirsty. In European countries or in your country, it's very easy to talk with a girl. In Afghanistan, maybe 90% of love is wrong love.
是的。举个例子，当你喝某种东西越来越多时，你就不会再渴了。在欧洲国家或你们的国家，和女孩交谈非常容易。在阿富汗，也许90%的爱情都是错误的爱情。
Nobody took Sabir's love very seriously, not his family, not Dr. Wasai, not even, apparently, Sabir himself. The only ones left to believe the love story were Miriam and Nikaj. Four months had passed since I'd last seen them. Nikaj had changed jobs, they'd lost touch with Sabir. They knew they were paying for a new wedding, but they didn't know the full story. So I sat them down on the couch.
没人把萨比尔的爱情当回事，他的家人没有，瓦赛医生没有，显然萨比尔自己也没有。唯一还相信这个爱情故事的只有米里亚姆和尼卡杰。距离我上次见到他们已经过去了四个月。尼卡杰换了工作，他们和萨比尔失去了联系。他们知道自己在资助一场新婚礼，但他们不知道全部实情。所以我让他们坐在沙发上。
I have good news and bad news. The good news is Sabir is getting married.
我有好消息和坏消息。好消息是萨比尔要结婚了。
Miriam was eight months pregnant, balancing a cup of green tea on her stomach. I told her about the new fiance, and she looked so disappointed.
米里亚姆已经怀孕八个月了，正挺着肚子小心地平衡着一杯绿茶。我告诉她关于那个新未婚妻的事，她看起来非常失望。
But does Sabir like this new girl?
但萨比尔喜欢这个新女孩吗？
Sabir hasn't seen her.
萨比尔还没见过她。
It's a crap shoot. That's not fair.
这纯属碰运气。这不公平。
He's going to be happy. His sisters checked the girl out. They talked with her mom, and they liked her, and thinks they are a match.
他会幸福的。他的姐妹们考察过这个女孩。她们和她妈妈谈过，她们很喜欢，觉得他们很般配。
But that's the problem, is that Sabir is a romantic guy. I think he has high expectations. If he were Mr. Joe Schmo, who didn't cry when he told a story or get the bad case of giggles, it wouldn't really matter if she wasn't the love of his life, because he's just another guy marrying another arranged girl and with no expectations. But that's not Sabir. Sabir is a sensitive kind of guy. And I think he expects to be happily ever after. And what if he's not?
但问题就在这儿，萨比尔是个浪漫的人。我觉得他期望很高。如果他是个普通人，讲故事时不会哭，也不会笑得止不住，那么她是不是他的挚爱并不重要，因为他只是另一个娶了包办婚姻对象的男人，没有任何期待。但萨比尔不是那样的人。他是个敏感的人。我觉得他期待着过上幸福的生活。如果他没得到呢？
The way Miriam had seen it, Sabir was a man who had glimpsed the promised land, the promise was true love. And she just wanted to help him get there. But now she has to face the fact that he was fine with an arranged marriage-- not just fine, happy. And by the end of our conversation, Miriam decided she was happy with whatever made Sabir happy.
在米里亚姆看来，萨比尔是一个瞥见过“应许之地”的男人，那承诺就是真爱。她只是想帮他到达那里。但现在她不得不面对一个事实：他完全接受包办婚姻——不仅是接受，而且很高兴。在谈话结束时，米里亚姆决定，只要萨比尔高兴，她就高兴。
I wanted him to see something he liked, go after it, and have it be his.
我只是想让他看见他喜欢的东西，去追求它，并把它变成他自己的。
But baby, this is Afghanistan.
但亲爱的，这是阿富汗。
Exactly, that's exactly the point. He and she found what they wanted, and it was an usual, out of the ordinary way of doing, and they did it. They would have done it, if he had married that girl. But instead, they just went back to the status quo. And that's not really what we're looking for. We weren't looking to fund an arranged marriage. We were looking to fund two people who fell in love.
没错，这正是重点。他和她找到了他们想要的，并以一种不同寻常的方式去做了。如果他娶了那个女孩，他们也会这么做。但相反，他们只是回到了现状。这并不是我们要寻找的东西。我们不是为了资助包办婚姻。我们是为了资助两个坠入爱河的人。
Well, just to make Sabir happy as well. And he needs a wife.
嗯，只是为了让萨比尔也高兴。而且他需要一个妻子。
We thought giving him Benjamin Franklins would make everything OK. And it wasn't just that, it was a little bit more complex. Sounds like a development project.
我们以为给他富兰克林（美元）会让一切变好。不仅仅是那样，这还要复杂一点。听起来像个发展项目。
Sabir says he's not planning to tell the new wife where their wedding money came from, at least, not till well afterwards. For now, he doesn't want her to know that he's doing anything different from the way things are always done.
萨比尔说他没打算告诉新妻子婚礼钱的来源，至少在很久之后才会说。目前，他不希望她知道自己在做任何与传统相悖的事。
Gregory Warner in Afghanistan, since we first aired this story last January, Sabir has gotten married in that arranged marriage, and says that he is a very happy man.
格雷戈里·沃纳在阿富汗。自去年一月我们首次播出这个故事以来，萨比尔已经通过包办婚姻结了婚，并说他是一个非常幸福的男人。
Coming up, fake babies, a fake nurse, and a bet that nobody wants to win. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
稍后，假婴儿、假护士，还有一个没人想赢的赌局。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共电台和国际公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring  you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show-- Matchmakers. We've arrived at act two of our show. Act Two, Part of Me, Why Not Take Part of Me. The woman in this next story was on our show briefly, once before, talking about how she donated a kidney as a good deed, and lied to her own mother about it until after the surgery.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。每周我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种不同类型的故事。今天的主题是——“媒人”。我们已经进入节目的第二幕。第二幕：我的一部分，为什么不带走我的一部分。下一个故事中的女子之前曾在我们的节目中短暂出现过，谈论她如何作为善举捐献了一个肾脏，并直到手术后才告诉她自己的母亲。
But after that experience, this woman, who's an orthodox Jewish woman named Chaya Lipschutz, started noticing all these ads where people were looking for donors, desperate people. And because she couldn't donate a second time herself, she decided to devote herself to rounding up potential kidney donors and matching them up with strangers in need of kidneys. She became, basically, a kidney matchmaker. Mary Robertson and Sarah Koenig co-reported this story which Sarah tells.
但那次经历之后，这位名叫查娅·利普舒茨（Chaya Lipschutz）的正统犹太教妇女开始注意到那些人们寻找捐赠者的广告，那些绝望的人们。由于她自己无法进行第二次捐赠，她决定全身心投入到搜寻潜在肾脏捐赠者，并将他们与需要肾脏的陌生人进行匹配的工作中。她基本上成了“肾脏媒人”。玛丽·罗伯逊（Mary Robertson）和萨拉·科尼格（Sarah Koenig）共同报道了这个故事，由萨拉讲述。
It's really, really hard to do what Chaya was trying to do. She's trying to persuade people, alive people, to give their kidneys to people they've never met, who don't necessarily live anywhere near them, who have nothing to do with them. Needless to say, people like this are very rare. For almost a year, Chaya posted ads on Craigslist in every state, under the volunteers section, seeking kidney donors.
查娅试图做的事真的非常非常难。她试图说服那些活生生的人，将肾脏捐给他们从未见过、可能住在离他们很远的地方、与他们毫无瓜葛的人。不用说，这样的人非常罕见。近一年来，查娅在每个州的 Craigslist 网站的志愿者版块发布广告，寻找肾脏捐赠者。
Life is exactly the same-- Oh, I should say, do you know. Life is exactly-- OK, no I could just say, life is exactly the same with two kidneys as one--
生活完全一样——噢，我应该说，你知道。生活完全——好的，我只能说，生活有两个肾和一个肾完全一样——
She updates the ads constantly, answers people who respond.
她不断更新广告，回复那些回应的人。
Hope you-- able to do this great act. Just think of how proud of you everyone who knows you will be.
希望你……能做这件伟大的事。想想你认识的人会为你感到多么骄傲。
But even when someone says they want to donate, maybe they don't follow through. And every hospital has different rules, so people get rejected all the time for different reasons. Or maybe there's a problem with their tests, or a family member talks them out of it. It can be constant frustration and disappointment. And for the first year of trying, it was. None of Chaya's matches went through.
但即使有人说他们想捐赠，他们可能也不会付诸行动。而且每家医院都有不同的规定，所以人们总是因为各种原因被拒绝。或者他们的检查结果有问题，或者家人劝阻他们。这可能是持续不断的挫折和失望。在尝试的第一年，确实如此。查娅促成的匹配没有一个成功。
An then Chaya got a break. This woman, Sandy, who heard Chaya give a talk about kidney donation at a synagogue, called Chaya up and said she wanted to donate and was all enthusiastic about it. And Chaya was thrilled. She matched her up with this guy, Max. The blood type was the same, and it was all working out.
然后查娅有了转机。一位名叫桑迪（Sandy）的女士在犹太教堂听了查娅关于肾脏捐赠的演讲后，打电话给查娅，说她想捐赠，而且非常热心。查娅欣喜若狂。她把桑迪与一个叫马克斯（Max）的男人匹配起来。血型一样，一切都很顺利。
She was very excited about it, because she happens to know the family. And she's good friends with the daughter. I was like, ah, perfect. So even when I told her that I have a back up, she didn't want to hear of it. This was her beshert. This is the person who was meant for her.
她对此非常兴奋，因为她恰好认识那个家庭，而且和女儿是好朋友。我就像：啊，太完美了。所以即使我告诉她我有候补，她也不想听。这就是她的“命运（beshert）”。这就是注定属于他的人。
Beshert is a Yiddish word that means destiny. And it's almost always used for romantic matches. And that's kind of how Chaya sees what she is doing. Not that it's romantic, of course, but that she's connecting strangers in the most intimate way possible. She hopes the people will bond. Maybe Sandy and Max will become like family to each other.
“Beshert”是一个意第绪语词汇，意为“命中注定”。它几乎总是用于浪漫匹配。这就是查娅看待自己工作的方式。当然，不是说它是浪漫的，而是她以最亲密的方式连接了陌生人。她希望人们能建立纽带。也许桑迪和马克斯会像家人一样。
Then on the day the surgery, when Sandy and Max were in the operating room, IVs in their arms and everything, they did a last minute blood test on Sandy. And it showed a problem, and the whole thing fell apart. Chaya was crestfallen. She left a message on my colleague Mary's machine, one of many, many, long messages about the Sandy situation.
然后在手术当天，当桑迪和马克斯在手术室里，手臂上扎着静脉滴注时，他们对桑迪进行了最后一次血液测试。结果显示有问题，整个计划告吹了。查娅心灰意冷。她在我的同事玛丽的录音机上留下了留言，那只是关于桑迪情况的许多条冗长留言中的一条。
Hi, Mary-- Chaya. I spoke to the kidney transplant coordinator at the hospital. And it's just a mess, it's just a mess--
嗨，玛丽，我是查娅。我和医院的肾脏移植协调员谈过了。这简直是一团糟，是一团糟——
And then, in the same message, Chaya is on to her next problem. This older guy, Abe Salem, had been waiting for kidney. But he'd gotten too sick for surgery, so she skipped over him. But now, he was ready, and she wasn't sure she had a donor. She'd originally offered up her brother to Abe, but then, when Abe got so sick, she matched up her brother with this other man instead, Mark Raymon. Now she's overwhelmed.
然后在同一条留言中，查娅又转向了下一个问题。这位年长者阿贝·塞勒姆（Abe Salem）一直在等待肾脏，但他病得太重无法手术，所以她跳过了他。但现在他准备好了，她却不确定是否有捐赠者。她最初把哥哥提供给了阿贝，但后来阿贝病重时，她把哥哥与另一个人匹配了，马克·雷蒙（Mark Raymon）。现在她不知所措。
I get clearance for Abe Salem. I didn't tell you that? Abe Salem is ready to have a kidney transplant. Good grief, what am I going to do now. Now they're all over my back with Salem's family. Oh, my goodness. It's crazy, it's crazy, so they want my brother now. Abe Salem wants my brother, Mark Raymon wants my brother. Bye.
我得到了阿贝·塞勒姆的许可。我没告诉你吗？阿贝·塞勒姆准备好进行肾脏移植了。天哪，我现在该怎么办。现在塞勒姆一家都在缠着我。噢，天哪。这太疯狂了，这太疯狂了，所以他们现在想要我的哥哥。阿贝·塞勒姆想要我的哥哥，马克·雷蒙也想要我的哥哥。再见。
Chaya's an unlikely agent for this line of work. She's not connected to a hospital. She's not a social worker. She's never been trained in the subtle, ethical considerations that go into living donor transplants. To be blunt, she's eccentric. She's excitable. And she's emotionally involved with the cases on her list.
查娅是这一行不太可能的代理人。她与医院没有联系，也不是社会工作者。她从未受过活体捐赠移植中微妙的道德考量方面的培训。直截了当地说，她古怪、激动，并且在情感上卷入了名单上的案件。
She doesn't strong-arm potential donors, but she does nudge and cajole. And she doesn't offer money, which is a illegal, but she does offer the promise that if you donate, people will think the world of you. You will feel gratified. It will boost your self-esteem. An expectation of quid pro quo which might horrify a professional transplant coordinator.
她不会强迫潜在的捐赠者，但她会推搡和诱哄。她不提供金钱，这是非法的，但她提供了一种承诺：如果你捐赠，人们会高度评价你，你会感到满足，这会提高你的自尊。这种“等价交换”的期待可能会让职业移植协调员感到恐惧。
Frankly, some hospitals are wary of Chaya and won't deal with her. But here she is, dedicating almost all her time, unpaid, trying to save these kidney patients. Within days of the Sandy disappointment, Chaya has rebounded and she's trying to match her brother, Yosef, with Mark Raymon. Abe, by this time, had dropped out again. If this works, it'll be her first successful match.
坦率地说，有些医院对查娅持谨慎态度，不愿与她打交道。但她一直在这里，无偿贡献了几乎所有时间，试图挽救这些肾脏病人。在桑迪失望后的几天内，查娅就反弹了，并试图将她的哥哥约瑟夫（Yosef）与马克·雷蒙匹配起来。此时阿贝再次退出。如果成功，这将是她第一个成功的匹配。
Mark, hi, good morning, it's Chaya. How are you?
马克，你好，早上好，我是查娅。你好吗？
Mark is 56. A computer guy who's been unable to work since his kidneys failed. He has to be on dialysis for three hours, three days a week. Dialysis is pretty horrible. It's nowhere near as effective as a new kidney, and people die on dialysis all the time. So Chaya is constantly on the phone and the email, working out the details of a possible transplant for Mark. the problem with this case is that her brother is willing to donate, but he needs to do it by the following week, because he has to get back to work.
马克56岁，一个电脑技术员，自肾脏衰竭以来一直无法工作。他必须每周三次、每次三小时进行透析。透析非常糟糕，效果远不如新肾脏，而且透析病人随时可能死亡。所以查娅不断地打着电话、发着邮件，处理马克可能进行移植的细节。这个案例的问题在于她哥哥愿意捐赠，但他必须在下周之前完成，因为他必须回去工作。
You know what, if you want my brother's kidney you're going to have to go out to Staten Island, not wait until next Monday or Tuesday, because it might be too late. I'm just suggesting strongly, if you want a kidney by next week-- I'm sorry. Yes, yes, if they can-- tell them there's a possibility you won't get a kidney if-- huh?
你知道吗，如果你想要我哥哥的肾脏，你得去斯塔滕岛，别等到下周一或周二，因为可能太晚了。我只是强烈建议，如果你想在下周得到肾脏——抱歉。是的，是的，如果他们能——告诉他们如果……呃？你可能得不到肾脏。
Mark Raymon and Yosef Lipschutz, Chaya's brother, go to the hospital in Brooklyn for their final round of tests, two days before the transplant is supposed to happen. Yosef, the donor, might be the sweetest man I've ever met. He's so nice, he thanks the nurses during routine questioning.
马克·雷蒙和查娅的哥哥约瑟夫·利普舒茨，在移植手术前两天去了布鲁克林的医院进行最后一轮检查。捐赠者约瑟夫可能是我见过最甜的人。他非常友善，在常规询问中感谢护士。
All right, any problems with your kidneys?
好的，你的肾脏有问题吗？
None whatsoever, thank you. Oh, thank  you.
完全没有，谢谢。噢，谢谢你。
He's never met Mark before, but they bumped into each other that morning at the admitting desk while they were signing in.
他以前从未见过马克，但那天早上他们在办理登记时在接待处撞见了。
He said that you're very kind to do this thing. I said, sure, my pleasure. And we discussed enough of the old neighborhood. He lives in Borough Park. I used to live in Borough Park. A little chitchat, nothing special--
他说你做这件事非常善良。我说，当然，这是我的荣幸。我们聊了足够多关于老社区的事。他住在区公园。我以前住在区公园。一些闲聊，没什么特别的——
We found Mark upstairs, waiting for his tests.
我们在楼上找到了马克，等待他的检查。
Did you have a vision in your head of what Yosef would look like, or how he would be, before you met him this morning?
在今天早上见到约瑟夫之前，你在脑海中设想过他长什么样，或者他会是什么样的人吗？
Not really, but he looks OK. He's not overweight. He looks basically OK.
没怎么想，但他看起来还好。他没有超重。他看起来基本还好。
So you were surveying him like for his health.
所以你像是在检查他的健康状况。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是的，是的，是的。
Sizing him up like--
像是在评估他——
I'd like to get a healthy kidney so that I can get on with my life.
我想得到一个健康的肾脏，这样我就可以继续我的生活。
Mark is pretty worried about the transplant. Not that it won't work, but that it won't happen. He's been through this before. About a year ago, he got to just about this stage of a transplant when the donor's family convinced her to back out. He was crushed.
马克对移植非常担心。不是担心它不会成功，而是担心它根本不会发生。他以前经历过。大约一年前，他几乎到了移植的那个阶段，捐赠者的家人说服她退出了。他彻底崩溃了。
Anything can go wrong. Even now, I mean, I coughed when I was being worked on by this lady inside, the nurse. She said, well if you're going to cough, that means you have a cold. If you have a cold, you can't be operated on. And if they try to postpone it, then my donor's going to run away, because he has a work schedule to keep up. So I'm not going to cough the next time. The next person I talk to, I'm not going to cough.
任何事都可能出错。即使是现在，我是说，当我被这个女士，那个护士检查时，我咳嗽了。她说：噢，如果你要咳嗽，说明你有感冒。如果你感冒了，就不能接受手术。如果他们试图推迟，那么我的捐赠者就会逃跑，因为他有工作时间表要遵守。所以我下次不会咳嗽。和我谈话的下一个人，我不会咳嗽。
So it's so tense.
所以太紧张了。
Yeah, that's right.
是的，没错。
Chaya's at the hospital too, making sure everything is moving ahead, making sure her brother's OK.
查娅也在医院，确保一切按计划进行，确保她哥哥没事。
I have a yogurt for you, and I brought a couple slices of whole wheat bread. We have to make sure your kidneys are going to stay in good health till Wednesday at least.
我给你带了酸奶，还有几片全麦面包。我们必须确保你的肾脏至少在周三之前保持健康。
She's a little agitated. Every few minutes, she adjusting this bobby pin that's in the back of her long dark hair, but that doesn't actually seem to be holding anything in place. And she's writing notes all the time on these little strips of cardboard that she keeps in her purse. I realize there the things you pull off the top of a Kleenex box. The hospital administration arranges a photographer to take a PR picture of  Mark and Yosef. It's a big thing for the hospital to have a stranger donate his kidney like this. So they put them next to each other on a bench, and it's incredibly awkward. They shake hands, pretend to meet again for the first time.
她有点焦虑。每隔几分钟，她就调整插在长黑发后部的发夹，但这似乎什么也没固定住。她一直在纸板小条上做笔记，她把这些小条放在钱包里。我意识到那是你从面巾纸盒顶部抽出来的东西。医院行政部门安排了一位摄影师为马克和约瑟夫拍摄公关照。 strangers捐赠肾脏对医院来说是件大事。所以他们让他们并排坐在长椅上，气氛异常尴尬。他们握手，假装第一次见面。
Nice meeting you, hopefully everything turns out all right.
见到你很高兴，希望一切顺利。
Got any hot tips on the stock market?
有什么关于股市的内幕消息吗？
No, it's no fun that.
没有，那没什么意思。
Chaya is beaming. She's got her camera out too. Everyone's feeling good. And Mark is starting to relax.
查娅满面红光。她也拿出了相机。每个人都感觉很好。马克也开始放松了。
Now I'm beginning to believe, God willing, that this is going to happen. Obviously, I've been disappointed before, but this time I believe this is, God willing, is going to be.
现在我开始相信，上帝保佑，这一切都会发生。显然我以前失望过，但这次我相信，上帝保佑，这会实现的。
Seconds after he says that, Vicki, the hospital's transplant coordinator, walks up and says she's got to talk to Yosef and Mark. She says, there's a little bit of a situation.
在他说完这话几秒钟后，医院的移植协调员薇基（Vicki）走过来，说她得和约瑟夫及马克谈谈。她说，有点小情况。
Can I tape this?
我可以录下来吗？
No, this is not good.
不行，这不太好。
OK.
好的。
A drug called Plavix showed up in one of Mark's blood tests. It's a blood thinner he takes. They'll have to postpone the surgery until the following Monday, when the Plavix will be out of Mark's system. But Monday is after Yosef's deadline, when he's supposed to be back at work. Chaya looks stricken. So does Mark. And then Vicki asks Yosef right there, in front of everybody, whether he'll still donate, even though he's said many times, he needs to have it done by the end of this week. Yosef pauses, and then says, he will.
在马克的血液测试中出现了一种叫“氯吡格雷（Plavix）”的药物。这是一种他服用的血液稀释剂。他们必须将手术推迟到下周一，届时氯吡格雷就会排出马克的系统。但下周一已经是约瑟夫工作截止日期之后了。查娅看起来悲痛欲绝。马克也是。然后薇基在众人面前直接问约瑟夫，他是否还会捐赠，尽管他多次表示他需要在本周末前完成。约瑟夫停顿了一下，然后说他会捐。
That was hard that they told you that right while he's sitting there. You can't refuse.
当他坐在那里时，他们直接告诉你这一点，太难了。你无法拒绝。
I can't refuse, number one and luckily, I have an open date sort of like next week. I just hope that it's not postponed anymore.
我不能拒绝，第一，幸运的是，我下周有一个空档。我只希望它不要再推迟了。
Too, just to have him sitting there like, what can you say.
第二，就让他坐在那里，你能说什么呢。
Well, I'm not going to break his heart. You know what I mean?
嗯，我不会伤他的心。你明白我的意思吗？
Could you see that he was looking heartbroken?
你能看出他看起来心碎了吗？
I felt it. I didn't have to look, I just could feel it.
我感觉到了。我不必看，我只是能感觉到。
Chaya sometimes downplays what she's doing, but this is huge for her, maybe her life's purpose. And in her circles, Orthodox Jewish circles, it's crucial that she have a purpose. I didn't realize this until I asked her what I thought was an innocent question, how old she was.
查娅有时会低估自己在做什么，但这对她来说是巨大的，可能是她的人生目标。在她的圈子里，正统犹太教圈子里，有一个目标至关重要。直到我问了一个我认为很天真的问题（她多大了）时，我才意识到这一点。
I don't  want to say. I don't want to say. Ask me another time.
我不想说。我不想说。下次再问我吧。
Wait, how come  you don't want to tell me how old you are?
等等，你怎么不想告诉我你多大了？
I don't want to say. I don't know, I don't want to say.
我不想说。我不知道，我不想说。
You don't want, in the story, for anyone to know how old you are?
你不想在故事里让任何人知道你多大了？
Right.
对。
Do you feel uncomfortable with your age?
你对自己的年龄感到不舒服吗？
Yeah, and you know why? Because I'm not married. And so it like looks strange. Someone my age should be married.
是的，你知道为什么吗？因为我没结婚。所以看起来很奇怪。我这个年纪的人应该结婚了。
In her world, a Jewish girl finishes high school and then gets married and has babies. It's what her sisters did, what her girlfriends did. Chaya came close, but it never happened. And now she's a woman of undetermined age, living with her elderly mother in a tiny, two room basement apartment in Borough Park, an Orthodox neighborhood in Brooklyn. Chaya's an anomaly here, and she feels it every day. She knows her landlady and the other tenants in the building probably talk about her.
在她的世界里，犹太女孩中学毕业后就结婚生子。这是她姐妹做的事，是她朋友做的事。查娅差点就做到了，但从未发生。现在她是一位年龄不详的女性，和年迈的母亲住在布鲁克林正统社区——区公园的一个狭窄、两室的地下室公寓里。查娅在这里是个异类，她每天都能感觉到。她知道她的房东和楼里的其他租户可能在背后议论她。
I don't know exactly what people are thinking, but I'm assuming like they see, they look at me like, oh, she's not married. And they probably say, oh, that's terrible. Or we feel bad for her. I'm sure they feel that way. I'm sure they feel that way. Yeah, you know, I kind of feel like an outsider, in a way, because I am different from them.
我不知道具体人们在想什么，但我假设他们看着我，就像：噢，她没结婚。他们可能会说，噢，那太糟糕了。或者我们为她感到难过。我肯定他们是那样想的。我肯定他们是那样想的。是的，你知道，我以某种方式感到自己是个局外人，因为我和他们不同。
That must be hard though to feel sort of different or even judged, or that people are out there like pitying you for something.
那种感觉有点不同，甚至被评判，或者人们在因为某事而怜悯你，那一定很难。
Yeah, yeah it does, it does. I do feel kind of funny about it. Like sometimes I do wonder, what are they thinking when they see me, whatever. They also could think there's something wrong with me mentally. But I feel bad for my mother, because I'm sure she has people say, oh, so how many children do you have, and how many children are married, and this and that. And I'm sure she'd love to say, all them. I know she probably skips the subject. Sometimes she tells me, now I know why, what your purpose in life is. And so she sees that maybe this was my purpose in life.
是的，是的，确实如此，确实如此。我对此感觉有点奇怪。比如有时我确实想，当他们看到我时，他们在想什么，随便吧。他们也可能认为我在精神上有什么问题。但我为我母亲感到难过，因为我肯定有人会对她说：噢，你有几个孩子？几个孩子结婚了？这个那个的。我肯定她很想说：都结婚了。我知道她可能避开这个话题。有时她告诉我：我现在知道为什么你的生活目标是什么了。所以她明白也许这就是我的人生目标。
So because Chaya can't call herself a wife or a mother, it's almost like, to her neighbors, she has no identity at all. She's had to find one, kidney matchmaker. But for that title to make sense, she has to actually arrange at least one successful match. It helps explain why she's so worried that something's going to go wrong on Monday, the day of the surgery. That morning, they do a final blood test on Yosef.
因为查娅不能称自己为妻子或母亲，对她的邻居来说，她简直没有任何身份。她不得不寻找一个：肾脏媒人。但要使这个头衔有意义，她必须至少安排一次成功的匹配。这有助于解释为什么她那么担心周一（手术日）会出岔子。那天早上，他们对约瑟夫进行了最后的血液测试。
But what if they took blood from him now, what if they find out something is not--
但如果他们现在取了他的血，如果他们发现有什么不对劲——
Like what?
像什么？
I don't know? What do they take, a CBC now and all that?
我不知道？他们取什么，现在取血常规之类的？
I mean I don't think--
我是说我不认为——
No, because-- listen. Anything can happen, even at last minute.
不，因为——听着。任何事都可能发生，即使是在最后一分钟。
It's 6:00 AM and Mark and Yosef are in a pre-op room separated by a curtain. A team of medical people is getting them ready. A doctor puts an x on Yosef's left side to mark which kidney they're going to take. Chaya's checking in on both of them. She takes the opportunity to lecture Mark a little.
现在是凌晨6点，马克和约瑟夫在手术室前的房间里，中间隔着帘子。一队医护人员正在为他们做准备。医生在约瑟夫的左侧打了一个叉，标记他们要取哪个肾。查娅正在查看他们两人。她趁机对马克进行了一点点说教。
Take good care of my brother's kidney when you get out of the hospital. Eat healthy, high fiber, low fat--
从医院出来后，一定要照顾好我哥哥的肾脏。吃得健康，高纤维，低脂肪——
I  plan on it.
我计划这样做。
That's the condition. If you want my brother's kidney, you got to take care of it and yourself.
这是条件。如果你想要我哥哥的肾脏，你必须照顾好它和你自己。
I'd plan on it.
我计划这样做。
Otherwise, he's going to take it back. I'm only kidding.
否则，他会把它收回去。我开个玩笑。
Mark doesn't say anything. Yosef's surgeon arrives.
马克没说什么。约瑟夫的外科医生到了。
We're on it. This is it. The moment of truth. Yeah, just grab the IV for me. Tell your sister you'll see her later, OK?
我们要开始了。就是现在。关键时刻。是的，帮我拿一下静脉滴注。告诉你的姐妹你稍后再见她，好吗？
OK.
好的。
The nurse just asked Yosef if he's ready to roll. Meaning, is he ready to have four small incisions to cut loose his kidney, and then a larger incision that the person with the smallest hand on the surgical team will reach into and pull out his kidney. The answer is yes. Yosef is ready to roll. Chaya hands over small holy book that she hopes will keep her brother safe.
护士刚才问约瑟夫是否准备好了。意思是，他是否准备好接受四次小切口来切除他的肾脏，然后是一个较大的切口，外科团队中手最小的人会伸进去取出他的肾脏。答案是肯定的。约瑟夫准备好了。查娅递给了一个她希望保护哥哥平安的神圣小书。
Say with me, [SPEAKING HEBREW].
跟我说，[希伯来语]。
And as soon as Yosef is out of sight--
当约瑟夫视线消失后——
You're going to be fine, don't worry.
你会没事的，别担心。
Chaya yells out to the surgeon. She's freaking out. She's still thinking this could all go wrong.
查娅向外科医生大喊。她快崩溃了。她还在想这可能一切都搞砸。
How will I know when they start the surgery, can somebody come out and say it's started? No. What time is it starting?
我怎么知道他们什么时候开始手术，有人能出来说它开始了吗？不。它是几点开始的？
Usually, it's going to start, I'd say in about 20 minutes from now.
通常，它会在20分钟后开始。
Because I don't want to leave. I want to know that it's started. I don't want to here that he backed out or something last minute.
因为我不想离开。我想知道它已经开始了。我不想听见他在最后一分钟退出了什么的。
I'll ask somebody to come out and let you know.
我会让人出来通知你。
Thank you very much, thank you, yes, thanks. You know what, don't-- I mean, it's not funny, because I know somebody who backed out the day of the surgery. I hope they lock the doors there.
非常感谢，谢谢，是的，谢谢。你知道吗，别——我是说，这不好笑，因为我认识一个在手术当天退出的人。我希望他们锁上那里的门。
Yosef doesn't run out of the operating room, and now Chaya just has to wait. One of her older sisters is there too, Aliza. They talk about the things you talk about when you're trying to pass five or six hours. Aliza has no trouble with this, she can really, really talk. About her own operations.
约瑟夫没有跑出手术室，现在查娅只需要等待。她的一位年长的姐妹也在那里，阿莉扎（Aliza）。她们聊着当你想打发五六个小时时会聊的话题。阿莉扎对此毫无困难，她真的真的能聊。关于她自己的手术。
I remember when I had my tumor on my ovary many, many years ago. And they had to operate. They had to do so much cutting. Today, thank the Almighty, they do so much cutting.
我记得多年前我卵巢长肿瘤时。他们不得不手术。他们不得不做这么多切割。今天，感谢全能者，他们做这么多切割。
About her bus driver on the way to the hospital.
关于她来医院路上的公交车司机。
He made a whole big deal about my shopping cart. Take the stuff out of the shopping cart. You can't come on the bus with a shopping cart. And I left, be well [SPEAKING YIDDISH] have a good day. I couldn't believe it. I don't know if he was Jewish. It doesn't matter. It was nice of him to say that.
他为我的购物篮大做文章。把东西从购物篮里拿出来。你不能带购物篮上车。我离开了，保重，[意第绪语] 有美好的一天。我不敢相信。我不知道他是不是犹太人。没关系。他能那样说真是太好了。
About the kosher joke book she's written.
关于她写的犹太洁食笑话书。
Two pelicans went into a restaurant, it's a corny joke, and they-- what do you call it-- they ate a meal. And they said where is the bill? The bill? They have a bill.
两只鹈鹕走进一家餐厅，这是一个老套的笑话，它们——你怎么称呼它——它们吃了一顿饭。它们说账单在哪里？账单？它们有一个账单。
Two pelicans go into a restaurant, they say where is the bill?
两只鹈鹕走进一家餐厅，它们说账单在哪里？
And then, finally, it's over. Everyone's fine. They can go visit Yosef. And it's at this moment that what Chaya has done suddenly becomes clear, most of all to her. For an instant, her single-minded kidney advocacy vanishes, and she's just a sister, looking at her brother, lying in the ICU.
最后，它结束了。每个人都很好。他们可以去探望约瑟夫。就在这一刻，查娅所做的一切突然变得清晰起来，尤其是对她自己。刹那间，她一心一意的肾脏倡导消失了，她只是一个看着躺在ICU里的哥哥的妹妹。
Hi, oh no, you look bad.
嗨，噢不，你看起来很糟。
He does look bad. He's barely conscious. And from the expression on his face, it seems like he's in too much pain to even speak.
他确实看起来很糟。他几乎没有意识。从他的表情看，他似乎疼得连话都说不出来。
Are you in pain?
你疼吗？
Yeah.
是的。
They tell you to squeeze some pain medicine?
他们告诉你要按点止痛药吗？
No.
不。
No? Should I ask them to do something?
不？我应该让他们做点什么吗？
Yes.
是的。
Excuse me, what are they going to do for his pain?
打扰一下，他们要为他的疼痛做什么？
Chaya had worried about this, about how much it would hurt him, how he would handle it when he woke up. She goes back out into the hall.
查娅担心这个，担心它会让他多疼，担心他醒来时会怎样处理。她回到大厅。
Are you OK?
你还好吗？
Yeah, I'm OK. [CRYING] I'm going to be OK.
是的，我还好。[哭泣] 我会没事的。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交谈声]
he's in  pain?
他疼吗？
Yeah. She says he's not in pain, and that  he's just very tired. Looked like he's falling asleep, which is good. Let him sleep maybe.
是的。她说他并不疼，他只是很累。看起来他快睡着了，这很好。让他睡吧。
And just like that, Chaya has snaps out of it. If she had any doubts about her purpose after seeing Yosef, they were fleeting. She goes back into his room and spends the rest of the day with him in recovery. After a couple of nerve-racking weeks of complications the transplant took. Yosef went back to work, and Mark did too. A year later, they're not really in touch. For her part, Chaya is still at it. In the past year, she's made two other successful matches, saved two more lives. And now she is not so anxious about the whole endeavor. She's proved to everyone that she's a bona fide matchmaker. Her mother is very proud.
就这样，查娅从那里面跳出来了。如果她在看到约瑟夫后对自己的目的有任何怀疑，那都是转瞬即逝的。她回到他的房间，在康复期陪了他余下的一天。经过两周令人紧张的并发症后，移植成功了。约瑟夫回去工作了，马克也是。一年后，他们没怎么联系。就她而言，查娅还在继续。过去一年里，她又促成了两次成功的匹配，挽救了两个生命。现在她对整个努力没那么焦虑了。她向所有人证明了她是一个名副其实的媒人。她的母亲非常自豪。
Sarah Koenig is one of the producers of our show. She co-reported that story with Mary Robertson.
萨拉·科尼格是我们节目的制作人之一。她与玛丽·罗伯逊共同报道了这个故事。
[MUSIC - "STRANGER IN LOVE" BY JOHN HOLT]
[音乐 - 约翰·霍尔特的《坠入爱河的陌生人》]
Act Three, Babies Buying Babies. Elna Baker always wanted to be an actress. But when she graduated from college, the only acting job she could get in New York City was at a toy store, FAO Schwarz, where they had salespeople put on costumes to demonstrate various toys. And this, is where Elna Baker accidentally got into the matchmaking game.
第三幕：婴儿购买婴儿。埃尔娜·贝克（Elna Baker）一直想成为一名演员。但当她从大学毕业时，在纽约市唯一能找到的表演工作是在一家玩具店，FAO Schwarz，那里的销售员戴着服装来展示各种玩具。就在这里，埃尔娜·贝克意外地进入了“媒人”游戏。
For the first few weeks I rotated from toy to toy so that Chad, the FAO toy demo manager, could analyze my acting strengths before placing me on a specific product. I demonstrated anything from Robo-transformers to plush puppets. There was a preschool veterinarian kit, and it came with a stuffed puppy and doctor tools. For six hours I was supposed to fake diagnose an inanimate object and get other people excited about it. I would interrupt families as they strolled through the store.
最初的几周，我轮流展示不同的玩具，以便 FAO 玩具演示经理查德（Chad）在安排我负责特定产品之前分析我的表演优势。我展示过从机器人变形金刚到长毛绒木偶的一切。有一个学龄前兽医工具包，里面有一个填充小狗和医生工具。六个小时里，我必须假装诊断一个无生命的物体，并让其他人对此感到兴奋。我会在家庭漫步经过商店时打断他们。
Spot is sick, will you help me figure out what's wrong with Spot? And then I would hand the child a stethoscope, while the parents waited impatiently. I might as well have said, you and your family want to be left alone, but I'm an actor.
“Spot生病了，你能帮我找出Spot出了什么问题吗？”然后我会递给孩子一个听诊器，而父母不耐烦地等着。我还不如说：你们和你们的家人想单独待着，但我是个演员。
After two weeks of rotating, I was assigned to the Lee Middleton Doll collection. This was a coveted position. Lee Middleton Dolls were special. We were told that they were made with materials developed by NASA. They looked exactly like real babies, and they were weighted in the head and in the bottom so that they actually flopped like real babies. Every day I dressed in a nurse's uniform, and I worked with two other nurses slash actresses in the adoption center, a small cottage on the second floor of a FAO Schwartz.
两周轮岗后，我被分配到了 Lee Middleton 玩偶系列。这是一个令人垂涎的职位。Lee Middleton 玩偶很特别。我们被告知它们是用 NASA 开发的材料制成的。它们看起来和真正的婴儿一模一样，头部和底部加了重物，所以它们确实像真正的婴儿一样晃动。每天我穿着护士制服，和另外两名护士/女演员在收养中心工作，那是在 FAO Schwartz 二楼的一个小屋。
A typical day of work would go as follows. Parents and their children would go from incubator to incubator admiring all the babies. If they decided that they were serious about adoption, we would open the gate to the white picket fence that surrounded the cottage and invite them inside. We would sit across from the perspective parent, usually a seven year old girl, in one of two rocking chairs and begin an adoption interview.
典型的工作日如下：父母和他们的孩子会从一个孵化器走到另一个孵化器，欣赏所有的婴儿。如果他们决定认真收养，我们会打开围绕小屋的白色尖桩栅栏的门，邀请他们进去。我们会坐在准父母（通常是一个七岁的小女孩）对面，坐在两把摇椅中的一把里，开始收养面试。
Do you promise to love and care for the baby? Will you read to the baby? Will you change the baby's diaper? Yes, the little girls would answer with sincerity. And then the final question, what would you like to name the baby? The girls always chose frilly names like Princess Tiffany of Fairy Flower Land. We would write Princess Tiffany on the doll's hospital bracelet, along with the date of birth, which usually happened to be the previous day. And then we would fill out a birth certificate. We would hand the birth certificate to the little girl's parents and say, now all you have to do is pay the adoption fee, wink, wink.
“你答应爱护这个婴儿吗？你会给婴儿读书吗？你会给婴儿换尿布吗？”“是的，”小女孩们诚恳地回答。然后是最后一个问题：“你想给婴儿起什么名字？”女孩们总是选择花哨的名字，比如“童话花之国的蒂芙尼公主”。我们会把“蒂芙尼公主”写在玩偶的医院手环上，以及出生日期，通常正好是前一天。然后我们会填写出生证明。我们会把出生证明交给小女孩的父母说：“现在你们只需要支付收养费，眨眨眼。”
We were instructed by Chad never to use words like cost, purchase, or buy. He said that that would quote, break the illusion of the world, unquote. When work got slow, us nurses were not allowed to socialize. According to Chad that would also break the illusion of the world. Instead, if we weren't working with a customer, we had to always be holding, rocking, or bouncing the display baby doll.
我们被查德指示绝对不要使用“成本”、“购买”或“买”之类的词。他说那会引用“打破世界幻想”。当工作变慢时，我们护士不允许社交。据查德说那也会打破世界的幻想。相反，如果我们不与顾客一起工作，我们必须始终抱着、摇晃或弹跳展示用婴儿玩偶。
The display baby doll is on display for a reason. It could not be sold. Something terrible happened in the factory on the day of its birth, because the dolls fingers were not like the other babies. They had been molded together making it look like it had flippers instead of hands. As if that weren't bad enough, it had curly red hair, scary green eyes, and its head weighed at least five pounds more than all the other babies' heads.
展示用婴儿玩偶放在展示台上是有原因的。它不能出售。在它出生的那一天，工厂里发生了可怕的事，因为玩偶的手指不像其他婴儿那样。它们被模塑在一起，使它看起来像有鳍状肢而不是手。如果这还不够糟糕，它还有卷曲的红头发，可怕的绿眼睛，头部重量至少比其他婴儿重五磅。
As a result, when you lifted the baby, its head would automatically flop back, and its little flippers would flip up like a monster baby. Which is how the doll earned its nickname. We called it Nubbins. And because Nubbins was for display purposes only, he didn't have an incubator like the other babies. Instead, he was kept in a cupboard. This was especially disturbing, because Nubbins had a knack for looking realistically dead. So when you'd open the cupboard, you'd find him slumped over onto his enormous head, with his arms flopped behind him like he died in a yoga class.
结果，当你抬起婴儿时，它的头会自动向后倒，它的小鳍状肢会向上翻，就像一个怪物婴儿。这就是玩偶昵称的由来。我们叫它 Nubbins。因为 Nubbins 仅用于展示目的，它没有像其他婴儿那样的孵化器。相反，它被放在一个橱柜里。这尤其令人不安，因为 Nubbins 有一种看起来像真正死掉的天赋。所以当你打开橱柜，你会发现它瘫倒在巨大的头上，双臂瘫在身后，就像死在瑜伽课上一样。
September and October are traditionally slow months at FAO Schwarz. And with no customers to attend to, we spent a lot of time holding, rocking, and bouncing baby Nubbins. So much time that we actually started to resent him. So to entertain ourselves we invented a game. Actually, I invented it, but the other girls went along with it. The object of the game was this, while a nurse was working with a customer, you had to try and get her to break character by doing something horrible to baby Nubbins.
九月和十月在 FAO Schwarz 传统上是淡季。由于没有顾客，我们花了很多时间抱着、摇晃和弹跳 Nubbins。花的时间太多以至于我们实际上开始怨恨它。为了娱乐自己，我们发明了一个游戏。实际上，我发明的，但其他女孩也参与了。游戏的目标是这样的：当一名护士与顾客工作时，你必须通过对 Nubbins 做一些可怕的事情来试图让她破功。
For example, I'd open all the doors to all the cabinets in the adoption center, and while another nurse was doing an adoption, I'd carefully walk down the aisle and rock Nubbins's head into the jagged edges of each drawer, while humming a lullaby.
例如，我会打开收养中心所有柜子的门，当另一名护士正在进行收养时，我会小心地走过过道，把 Nubbins 的头摇进每个抽屉的锯齿边缘，同时哼着摇篮曲。
It was fun to torture Nubbins in front of each other, but it was even better when there was a crowd of people standing outside the adoption center. It took real comedic timing. You'd change Nubbins's diaper on the diaper changing table. Then you'd carefully lift him. You'd gently place him on your shoulder and burp him ever so slightly. And at just the right moment, you'd drop him.
在彼此面前折磨 Nubbins 很有趣，但在收养中心外面站着一群人时更好。这需要真正的喜剧时机。你会给 Nubbins 换上尿布台上的尿布。然后你小心地抱起它。轻轻地把它放在肩上，非常轻地拍打它。在恰当的时候，你把它扔掉。
It worked every time. Everyone watching knew Nubbins wasn't real, but when he hit the floor, they still jumped and gasped. And the best part was that they did it sync, so it looked like a minor earthquake had just occurred. That is how us nurses spent our time. We'd sell overpriced dolls when we had customers, and we'd torture Nubbins when we didn't. And then one day, everything changed.
这每次都有效。每个观看的人都知道 Nubbins 不是真的，但当它撞到地板时，他们仍然跳起来并喘息。最好的是他们同步做了，看起来像发生了轻微地震。这就是我们护士消磨时间的方式。有顾客时我们就卖昂贵的玩偶，没顾客时我们就折磨 Nubbins。然后有一天，一切都变了。
A few months before I started working as a toy demonstrator, two girls from the MTV reality show, Rich Girls , came in to FAO Schwartz with a camera crew and adopted a baby. On November 15th the episode aired. By 9 o'clock the next morning, every mother on the Upper East Side had to have a Lee Middleton Doll for her child.
在我开始作为玩具演示员工作的前几个月，MTV 真人秀《富家女》中的两个女孩带着摄像组来到 FAO Schwartz 并收养了一个婴儿。11月15日剧集播出。第二天早上9点，上东区每位母亲都必须为她的孩子买一个 Lee Middleton 玩偶。
There was a line of anxious parents and spoiled children outside the store. We were doing adoptions left and right. Gone were the days of horseplay and pranks. This was real work, and it was exhausting. Do you promise to love and care for the baby? Will you read to the baby? Will you change the baby's diaper? What do you want to name the baby? Fill out birth certificate, repeat.
店外有一排排焦虑的父母和被宠坏的孩子。我们一直在进行收养。嬉戏和恶作剧的日子一去不复返了。这是真正的工作，而且很累人。“你答应爱护这个婴儿吗？你会给婴儿读书吗？你会给婴儿换尿布吗？你想给婴儿起什么名字？”填写出生证明，重复。
Business was so good that no one saw it coming until it was too late. Within a week of the episode's air date, we sold out of all the white babies. That's right, we sold out of all the white babies. All we had left were incubator upon incubator of minority babies.
生意太好了，以至于没人预见到，直到太晚了。在剧集播出后的一周内，所有的白人婴儿都卖光了。没错，所有的白人婴儿都卖光了。我们剩下的只有孵化器里一堆少数族裔婴儿。
The manager of FAO Schwarz had a conniption fit. With Christmas only five weeks away, the Lee Middleton factory was already on back-order. There was absolutely no way to get a new shipment in until mid-January.
FAO Schwarz 的经理气急败坏。圣诞节只有五周时间，Lee Middleton 工厂已经在缺货状态。直到一月中旬绝对不可能有新货运到。
Day after day, the same scenario would repeat itself. Eager mothers would rush to the adoption center. Is this the  Lee Middleton Doll collection, they'd ask. Then they'd stop, dead in their tracks. I'd watch their heads go from incubator to incubator. They'd pause briefly at the Asian baby. Oh-- no. And then, trying as hard as they could be politically correct, the mothers would look at us and say, do you have any other shades of babies?
一天又一天，同样的场景不断重复。急切的母亲会冲进收养中心。“这是 Lee Middleton 玩偶系列吗？”她们问。然后她们停下来，死在轨道上。我看她们的头从一个孵化器转到另一个。她们在亚洲婴儿面前短暂暂停。“噢……不。”然后，尽可能努力地表现出政治正确，母亲们看着我们说：“你们还有其他色调的婴儿吗？”
Chad, the toy demo manager, had prepped us  with a response. He'd taped a memo in the women's locker room reading, if the mother's express a disinterest in the babies due to ethnicity, kindly inform them that while these are all the babies we have in stock, there's a wider selection available online. And they're more than welcome to order online.
查德，玩具演示经理，为我们准备了一个回复。他在女性储物柜里贴了一张备忘录，写着：“如果母亲因种族原因表示对婴儿没兴趣，请善意地通知她们，虽然这些是我们目前库存的所有婴儿，但在线有更广泛的选择。她们非常欢迎在线订购。”
But this is not what the mothers wanted to hear. These dolls don't look like my little Susan, they'd explain, pointing to their child. I want something that looks like Susan, wink, wink. Us nurses decided to make the most of the situation. And so we invented another game.
但这不是母亲们想听到的。“这些玩偶看起来不像我的小苏珊，”她们解释，指着她们的孩子。“我想要看起来像苏珊的，眨眨眼。”我们护士决定充分利用这种情况。于是我们发明了另一个游戏。
If a mother didn't want to adopt a doll because of its ethnicity, we worked on her child. It was pretty easy. First, we would ask the little girl  if she wanted to hold one of the babies. Wow, we'd exclaim. This little baby has really taken to you. You look like you'd make an excellent mommy for her. The little girls would gently stroke the babies while the mothers would look at us in a state of panic. You could almost hear them thinking, why are you doing this to me? What did I ever do to you?
如果一位母亲因为族裔原因不想收养玩偶，我们就从她的孩子入手。这很容易。首先，我们会问小女孩她是否想抱一个婴儿。“哇，”我们会感叹。“这个小婴儿真的很喜欢你。你看起来会成为她出色的妈妈。”小女孩们会温柔地抚摸婴儿，而母亲们会处于惊恐状态看着我们。你几乎可以听到她们在想：你们为什么要这样对我？我以前对你们做过什么？
The other game we invented stemmed from Chad's memo. Instead of saying, there's a wider selection available online, we would try and say, there is a whiter selection available online, without getting caught or breaking character. In spite of these games, the situation still depressed me. I remember one mother in particular. She was in her mid-30s with blond hair and a pinched face. When I offered her an Hispanic baby, she looked at me and said, Oh, come on. We don't want a dark child. What would people think it Jessica was carrying a dark baby? She touched my hand and looked into my eyes. You know what I mean.
我们发明的另一个游戏源于查德的备忘录。与其说“在线有更广泛的选择”，我们尝试说“在线有更白的选择”，而不被抓到或破功。尽管有这些游戏，这种情况仍然让我沮丧。我记得一位特别的母亲。她30多岁，金发，尖脸。当我向她提供一个西班牙裔婴儿时，她看着我说：“噢，算了吧。我们不想要一个黑皮肤的孩子。如果杰西卡带一个黑皮肤婴儿，别人会怎么想？”她摸着我的手，看着我的眼睛。“你知道我的意思。”
I knew what she was trying to say. She was saying that since we were both white, I understood her. But what she didn't know is that while I'm fair-skinned, I'm actually half-Mexican. And besides that, I did not know what she meant. Did she honestly think that if someone saw her daughter carrying a Hispanic baby doll that they would think that Juan, her gardener, had knocked her up?
我知道她想说什么。她是说因为我们都是白人，我理解她。但她不知道的是，虽然我是白皙的，但我实际上是一半墨西哥人。除此之外，我不知道她是什么意思。她真的认为如果有人看到她的女儿带一个西班牙裔婴儿玩偶，她们会认为她的园丁胡安让她怀孕了吗？
There were so many things I wanted to say to these mothers. But that's when it sucks to be employed, because the customer's always right. So instead of speaking up, I took my hand out from under the pinched-face woman's and said, you are more than welcome to order online. There's a whiter selection available online.
有很多话我想对这些母亲说。但当被雇佣时这很烂，因为顾客永远是对的。所以我不说话，而是从那个尖脸女人的手下抽出我的手说：“非常欢迎在线订购。在线有更白的选择。”
But this was only half of the story. Technically, we hadn't sold out of all the white babies. Technically, we still had one left, Nubbins. As a result, when mothers would rush to the adoption center and realize there were only minority babies, they'd immediately notice Nubbins. They'd spot him in our arms, round and pudgy with a head of red hair. He was the answer to their prayers.
但这只是故事的一半。技术上，我们没有卖光所有的白人婴儿。技术上，我们还剩下一个，Nubbins。结果，当母亲们冲进收养中心意识到只有少数族裔婴儿时，她们会立即注意到 Nubbins。她们会在我们怀里发现它，圆圆胖胖，顶着一头红发。它是她们祈祷的答案。
Can I see that baby? They would insist. All we ever had to do was turn Nubbins around. His head would flop back. His flippers would flip up. And the mothers would quickly say, never mind. This happened so often that eventually us nurses decided to make a bet. Who do you think will go first, baby Nubbins or all the minority babies?
“我能看看那个婴儿吗？”她们会坚持。我们所要做的只是把 Nubbins 转过来。它的头会向后倒，它的鳍状肢会向上翻。而母亲们会迅速说：“算了吧。”这种情况发生得太频繁以至于我们护士最终决定打赌。你认为谁会先卖掉，婴儿 Nubbins 还是所有少数族裔婴儿？
To be honest, when I've told this story in the past, and I've told it a number of times, I've said that I bet on the minority babies, because I thought Nubbins would be the last to go, if he'd go at all. And then what I'd say happened was that Nubbins sold first, leaving behind an entire toy nursery of minority babies and isn't that crazy. But that wasn't exactly true. What actually happened was much harder to admit. It was this. The minority babies did start to sell, slowly.
老实说，当我过去讲述这个故事时，而且我讲过很多次，我说我押在少数族裔婴儿上，因为我认为 Nubbins 是最后一个卖掉的，如果它卖掉的话。然后我说发生的是 Nubbins 先卖掉，留下了整个玩具苗圃的少数族裔婴儿，那不是太疯狂了吗。但那不完全是真的。实际发生的情况更难承认。就是这样。少数族裔婴儿确实开始卖掉，慢慢地。
First, we sold out of all the Asian babies. Then we sold out of all the Hispanic babies. And finally, all we had left was Nubbins and incubators of black baby dolls. This just made us all feel worse. Inadvertently, the bet had become, who do you think will go first, Nubbins or every black baby in the nursery. I stood by my initial bet. We'll never sell Nubbins, I insisted.
首先，我们卖光了所有的亚洲婴儿。然后我们卖光了所有的西班牙裔婴儿。最后，我们只剩下了 Nubbins 和一堆黑人婴儿玩偶。这让我们感觉更糟。无意中，打赌变成了：你认为谁会先卖掉，Nubbins 还是苗圃里的每个黑人婴儿。我坚持我的最初赌注。“我们永远不会卖掉 Nubbins，”我坚持。
And then a week later, a mother marched up to the adoption center. Nurse, she yelled, is this some sort of a joke? Her face was frozen in disgust. In one hand, she was holding a Bergdorf shopping bag, with the other she was dragging a very solemn child. Where are all the white babies?
然后一周后，一位母亲走到收养中心。“护士，”她喊道，“这是某种玩笑吗？”她的脸因厌恶而僵住。一只手拿着 Bergdorf 购物袋，另一只手拖着一个非常庄重的孩子。“所有的白人婴儿在哪里？”
I wasn't used to the mothers being quite so direct. We're all out, I said. You have got to be kidding, she began. And then her eyes focused on Nubbins, who was nestled in my arms. What about that one, she asked.
我不习惯母亲们如此直接。“都卖完了，”我说。“你一定是在开玩笑，”她开始说。然后她的眼睛聚焦在 Nubbins 上，它依偎在我的怀里。“那个怎么样？”她问。
I turned Nubbins around, slowly, for full impact. His head flopped back. His flippers flipped up. I waited for her horrified response. We'll take it, she said. What, I thought, Nubbins? You want to adopt Nubbins? Was Nubbins even up for adoption? I opened the white picket fence and escorted the mother and her daughter over to the rocking chairs. I sat baby Nubbins in the solemn little girl's lap, sat in the seat across from her and began.
我慢慢地转动 Nubbins，以获得充分的效果。它的头向后倒。它的鳍状肢向上翻。我等待她惊恐的反应。“我们要它，”她说。“什么，”我想，“Nubbins？你想收养 Nubbins？Nubbins 甚至可以收养吗？”我打开白色尖桩栅栏，护送母亲和她的女儿到摇椅上。我把婴儿 Nubbins 放在那个庄重的小女孩膝盖上，坐在她对面的座位上开始。
Do you promise to love and care for this baby? The little girl looked up at me. No. I had been doing adoptions for two months now. I'd interviewed hundreds of little girls. No one had ever answered no before. Technically she had just failed the adoption interview. For lack of a better response, I ignored her answer, and I moved on to the next question. Will you read to the baby? No. OK, I said, moving to the next question. What would you like to name the baby? Stupid, she said.
“你答应爱护这个婴儿吗？”小女孩抬头看着我。“不。”我已经做收养工作两个月了。我面试了数百个小女孩。从来没有人回答过“不”。技术上她刚在收养面试中失败。由于没有更好的反应，我忽略了她的回答，转向下一个问题。“你会给婴儿读书吗？”“不。”“好的，”我说，转向下一个问题。“你想给婴儿起什么名字？”“愚蠢，”她说。
While I wasn't exactly Nubbins's best friend, I wasn't about to write Stupid on his birth certificate. Why don't we try calling him-- Just name the baby Veronica, her mother interrupted. I scribbled Veronica in the name section of the baby bracelet and birth certificate and then I handed the paperwork to the mother.
虽然我不是 Nubbins 最好的朋友，但我没打算把“愚蠢”写在它的出生证明上。“我们为什么不试着叫它——只是把婴儿命名为维罗妮卡（Veronica），”她母亲打断。我在婴儿手环和出生证明的名字部分潦草地写下“维罗妮卡”，然后我把文书工作交给母亲。
As they walked away, I laid out a pink blanket instead of a blue one, and set Nubbins in the center. For the last time, his head flopped back, and his little flippers flipped up. That's when it hit me. Nubbins has been adopted. There will be no more Nubbins. A little montage in honor of the doll began to play in my head. There he was being tossed across the adoption center by Jenny. There was the time Carla had accidentally rocked on him with rocking chair, and a crowd gasping as he tumbled onto a marble floor.
当她们走开时，我铺了一条粉红色的毯子而不是蓝色的，把 Nubbins 放在中间。最后一次，它的头向后倒，小鳍状肢向上翻。就在那时我击中了。Nubbins 被收养了。将不再有 Nubbins。一段向玩偶致敬的小蒙太奇在我的脑海里开始播放。那里有它被珍妮扔过收养中心。那是卡拉不小心用摇椅摇它的时候，当它滚到大理石地板上时人群惊呼。
It had never occurred to me before, but I loved Nubbins. And if I sold baby Nubbins, what it meant was just too depressing. I mean, after all the weird comments from our customers about our baby inventory, I still didn't want to face what it said if a factory reject monster baby was adopted before a whole nursery of perfectly cute black babies. I tried to think of ways to prevent this. I thought about lying and telling them Nubbins had already been purchased. I even thought about buying Nubbins myself. I imagined what I'd say to my dad when I called him to borrow the $120. Um, dad, there was this baby at the adoption center, and he was about to go to a bad family, and I think that I could be a good family.
我以前从没想过，但我爱 Nubbins。如果我卖掉了婴儿 Nubbins，它的意思太令人沮丧了。我是说，在顾客对我们的婴儿库存发表所有奇怪评论后，如果一个工厂淘汰的怪物婴儿在苗圃里一堆完美可爱的黑人婴儿之前被收养，我仍然不想面对它所说的。我试图想办法阻止这一点。我想过撒谎，告诉她们 Nubbins 已经买走了。我甚至想过自己买 Nubbins。我想象当我打电话给爸爸借那120美元时我会说什么。“嗯，爸爸，收养中心有一个婴儿，它快要到一个坏家庭了，我觉得我能成为一个好家庭。”
And then I looked up. The woman and her daughter had returned with their receipt. Reluctantly, I placed baby Nubbins in the little girl's arms. I'm sure baby Veronica will have a wonderful home, I lied. As she and her mother walked out of the store, I watched Nubbins's head bobbing on her shoulder until I couldn't see them anymore.
然后我抬头看。女人和她的女儿带着收据回来了。我不情愿地把婴儿 Nubbins 放在小女孩的怀里。“我相信婴儿维罗妮卡会有一个美好的家，”我撒谎道。当她和她的母亲走出商店时，我看着 Nubbins 的头在她的肩膀上晃动，直到我看不到她们。
Elna Baker performs her stories on stage around New York City, and she has a book coming out, The New York Regional Mormon Singles Halloween Dance, a Memoir .
埃尔娜·贝克在纽约市各地的舞台上表演她的故事，她有一本书即将出版，《纽约地区摩门教单身万圣节舞会，回忆录》。
Well, our program was produced today by Jane Feltes with our senior producer Julie Snyder, and with Alex Blumberg, John Jeter, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollack, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Production help from Seth Lind and Emily Youssef.
嗯，我们的节目今天由简·费尔特斯制作，高级制作人朱莉·斯奈德，以及亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格、约翰·杰特、萨拉·科尼格、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。阿德里安娜·马修韦茨运营我们的网站。制作帮助来自塞思·林德和艾米丽·优素福。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助信用]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for a program by our boss Mr. Torey Malatia who is always stopping me in the hallway to share his feelings about me.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。WBEZ 对我们老板托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）的节目管理监督，他总是拦住我分享他关于我的感受。
If it was possible, I will take your hair on my head."
“如果可能的话，我会把你的头发长在我的头上。”
And um, what exactly does that mean?
嗯，那到底是什么意思？
It means-- know he is in love.
这意味着——知道他坠入爱河。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。